what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation about to watch the finale
of the Rings of power where we learn
that Aaron dear with Sauron this whole
time
playing the long game that's your deal
man how could you that's your deal why
oh well I liked you dude watch Watch Me
Be Right watch this happen it'll happen
ladies and gentlemen leave a like I
would really appreciate that personally
also subscribe for whatever reason you
want to subscribe for and full-length
Reaction watch along as we single with
your own copy for the rings of power
available for our super sexy Rejects at
our patreon page thank you thank you
thank you to all who have joined and
shown your support it really means the
world anyhow let's see what's in store I
hope they stick the land
foreign
Ty
hello you
if you want it come and claim it
two little men no ripped us
what
no I think it's a mislead
what has happened
I don't think that was meant to be funny
he's gemstones I've never seen anything
like them what do you plan to use them
for Sauron
gotta be where I came up precious metals
was scarce as hens teeth so we learned
to combine them on his strengths and
hide floors I've seen a trace of nickel
added to iron to make a blade lighter
and stronger alloy to amplify the
qualities of Euro wow caliber and bore
sounds like you're not as great as
people make you out to be you never
thought basic blacksmith knowledge
in the coming days each of you will be
granted one hour with the King use it
well
you got that no I guess so yeah in an
hour yeah yeah you're mistaken I'm clean
yet no but you will be so know this if
the old ways of our people are not soon
restored our Island will fall
oh my goodness all the kings be dying
and mistaking people for other people
lately I know it sounds strange hiking
but surely we should exhaust every
possible solution precisely what manner
of object
it would be smaller than previously
imagined something that could be carried
a scepter perhaps a sword or perhaps
a crown or a ring a ring it was only in
speaking with the southlander that I
realized hello man this idea was his his
suggestions were about the key that
unlocked the dam we are on the coast it
was really my idea I did most of this
you just added one little thing you are
hereby Commander to disband the city
I need Royal lineages floodlights
anything you can find on the Southlands
I shall have to scour the catacombs for
that information three weeks
all of a sudden the two of you seem
quite familiar I'm just suffering
whatever humble Aid I can it's like a
completely different guy I'd ever given
up you
you believed in me he pushed me to
Heights that no one else could have I
will never forget that even when I'm the
dark lord and I'll see to it than no one
else does either
what what a line because I'm gonna have
power to do it yeah they'll listen to me
I'm Sauron you fell from the Stars yet
you are greater than they for fire obeys
your will you you fell below the dust Oh
Our Lord
oh no
[Music]
oh
I don't see christ-like imagery
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
you're such a nice guy
[Music]
oh
cool
[Music]
calm yourself
Dory
hey
[Music]
whoa
oh my God it's like when Gandalf fought
a Saruman
[Applause]
Wowie
oh
ouch
my God you are destroying the
environment every episode
where I I will hurt you again what is it
done to you they showed me what I am
only you can show what you are you
choose
what
you
do
that's not who I am underneath you are
who you choose to do it defines me you
choose oh
[Music]
to Shadow I bid you return
[Music]
wow oh
dang
[Music]
whoa
oh
that's cool
kind of like the army of dunharrow for a
minute yeah that's what I thought but I
don't think they are because I don't
remember them turning into butterflies
nope
hold still
we'll find a way to carry it back
sorry good lady go to the magic man just
saved your asses
if you don't mind I just like to sit a
while
watch the sun come up
do something dude he can't what he's got
to be able to do something he can heal a
knife wound bring him grow the
population of a dead Forest I'm sure he
can do that man yet at every turn I made
the choices I did because the lender
does not merely mean one who loves the
Stars I just ever imagined they wouldn't
leave oh wow one who loves his Queen it
may take time time we don't have time
perhaps that is enough for today perhaps
we've been pushing ourselves too hard
pushing ourselves too hard that's rich
coming from you galadria
that's it so we need to push it hard
supposing we've been using too much
force the metals shouldn't be forced to
join but more drawn or coaxed together
now if that's true we've been here we've
been doing it all inside oh Brian you
should have his job even solving every
step of the world you you really have
we're making two two crowns not exactly
it'll need to be something smaller or
rounder smaller
come see for yourself well Adriel I'm
afraid I don't there's no king of
the last man to Bear your Crest died
over a thousand years ago wow
in that time
I have had many names ugh
he's not such a bad guy
[Music]
you fought so hard for so many years to
complete the tasks that I could not
avenging Me Do You Remember
what I whispered to you under this very
tree touch the darkness once more
he's a creepy brother my brother is dead
because of you come back to me Galadriel
look at me
you know who I am I am your friend you
are a friend of morgoths we're not just
saying out
no whatever I'd done before I could be
free of it you deceived me I told you
the truth I told you that I had done
evil and you did not care
because you knew that our past meant
nothing weighed against our future
there is no such future yeah but it's
one of the guys who were just a regular
dude yeah
oh my God
trolling The Sound Stage
oh
damn that's a cool shot yeah
I alone could see your greatness
little
you told me what we were brought
together for a purpose this is it you
bind me to the light and I bind you to
power together
safe
a little bit
what will they do when you tell them
that you are my Ally when you tell them
that Sauron lives because of you but you
will die
oh
damn
swim Galadriel do some clever rope
cutting maneuver thing
where did we first meet
Seaside when I was first orphaned
where is he Workshop it'll almost be
finished by now man they got done with
these Rings really fast yeah
what is Hal Brad
he's gone
and I doubt he will return
and should he ever none of us start to
treat with him again
what happened by that stream
he spoke to me once a mistake
so do we proceed no
let's make three
uh
I have determined that the purity of the
Lesser wars in the alloy
is crucial I need gold and silver of the
most Exquisite quality
yes I need golden silver from Valen home
let's go
true creation requires
no sacrifice
you should definitely tell them that
Sauron
I'm just saying
War has come but to discover the rest
I know I must go till roon hey he's
speaking normally man they called you
something else
you start
is that your kind in your tongue that
means wise one
mm-hmm
wizard
hey we're here with every common theory
is coming true that's right we got again
batons our paths are laid before us by
Powers greater than our own in those
moments it's our task to make our feet
go where our hearts wish Not To Tread no
matter the perils awaiting us on the way
perils yourselves a bit like an
adventure
alone it's just a journey
an unexpected one I wish the old cult
was still with us
yes
they really couldn't save Santa I can't
get over that yeah it seems like or at
least try like again easy
your power to something bigger now
wow really
you belong out there
you're an adventure in hard foot that's
why Gandalf started to like little
people
[Music]
I is star and you fell from the stars
and it means Wizards as well as one
wizard there's those three dumb asses
couldn't possibly think that was the
other thing
no they just find the first sign it
might be them and go for it
here you're heading in the big Beyond
and I haven't talked to you blipping
sure you have always quench your fire
water and Earth don't squash by a river
never know when you'll need a drink down
the stream the hard foot without manners
is his loyal to get far in life
as a square
oh
damn find where the river runs
where The Sparrows learn their songs and
I'll be careful
you'll be bold
no no
this is touching when the hobbits leave
there they're always like Oh yay I'm
leaving good go on an adventure I'm
really gonna see the people you leave
behind
fires Poppy
[Music]
you're my best friend in this whole wide
wild world
the world's not that why he's poppy it's
so where's somebody small
are you certain more than ever
well they're all wavy in you
[Music]
if I turn around I won't ever be able to
leave
well then perhaps it would be best if
you lead off
hmm
damn you have like really come into your
own
know that it comes to us my feet feel
heavy as iron
an awesome adventure I haven't in
England which way to go
oh
[ __ ]
there it is are you sure
there's a sweet smell on the air this
way
when in doubt
Eleanor Brandy foot
always follow your nose always follow
your nose
foreign
we should actually make maybe 10 of
these things
or 17 20 I don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
where did sarongo
[Music]
[Music]
it's a big ass ring they're gonna make
that's a bangle
[Music]
the eye
this is such a cheeky show
[Music]
[Music]
what what feeling do you have
[Music]
ha ha ha
[Music]
wait stop been in the water all that
time just stuck by The Rock
something's not right
it's Galadriel Galadriel Sauron yeah
that's it
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
's real or digital I know right
probably digital
[Music]
[Laughter]
there it is there's my man
[Music]
homeboy made it over here fast one does
simply walk into Mordor
who
they're ruining the the future of the
show stop it it's only three
God damn it spoilers you're spoiling the
shares
one corrupts
this is a great cover
yeah cover of a monologue
all right John what did you think I
thought this was a pretty solid finale
it was quite uh gripping and thrilling
and all that stuff I feel like you know
we got a whole whole lot in terms of uh
at least some clarifications some
reveals the Rings obviously it felt like
a lot of stuff happened comparatively
um but I enjoyed it I I was here for the
ride and I was pretty swept up in it
most of the time there were a couple
moments that pulled me out that I think
are pretty obvious if you watch the
reaction
um but yeah I mean this
for the discourse we've had over the
course of the season and the sort of up
and down journey of all this uh I
thought it was a pretty strong finale
and it does get me you know curious and
and anticipant toward what's to come
certainly I feel like you know there are
obviously things about the season that
could have been a bit more Rich uh but
this episode in terms of all the
elements that we know the show has
coming together then plus the writing I
thought this did a pretty solid job in
wrapping everything up for the first
chapter here and you know giving me
something at least to kind of look
forward to in the future but what did
you think
yeah it was good it's good uh I I liked
it overall I definitely wasn't bored no
I was I was very entertained
felt uh appropriately fantasy cheesy the
entire time sure I'm good very soap
opera
but then uh my favorite stuff is when I
feel like what this show really wants to
do is do some dark [ __ ] everyone because
that's when the show really seems to
shine not just because it's my personal
sensibility that I'm most drawn to I
really get the impression that when
they're having
their true creative juices flowing I'm
making something that can really sing
it's when they're doing like the Sauron
reveal wow
I don't know it's like I've heard it
since like the second episode that you
saw run and I guess the performance I'm
so curious to go back and watch this and
go
I don't know if it's really Alonso
because part of a reveal like that Tim
to me is not really the facts of like
yes it lines up that he took a man's
identity and and whatever and that
there's no real king of the Southland
like that all lines up sure that's easy
to believe
it's it's really
was there an indicator of the
performance because I was like man he
must have like gone deep undercover here
really had to sell people on all these
stories until he just seemed like he
would such the extra mile and then by
the time he like woke up in the Elven
place
I could barely contain my glee no one's
even asked about my wound
I'm just up and about looking around
giving ideas freely yeah here we go so
excited I
I I I'm curious to see if like the I
feel like something like that you gotta
have like some parts and maybe other
people did because it's like yes I heard
every clue that that it was him and I'm
like yeah I buy it but there's just
something about the performance I'm not
really buying you know like because I
haven't even made a joke last week of
he was really going the extra mile to
sell people he's not sorrow I don't know
I was like I guess he was because it's
not surprising he saw her on but there's
just something about the way it was it
was handled of like there is no King I'm
like he came this far and you're just
like
mind prison Journey pretty much it
clinches the whole thing rather than
being like it's it's I get that he's
trying to persuade her in that moment
but also I'm like you could have gone
with a little bit more of a pedestrian
approach yeah or maybe I'll make the
brother seem like he's about to do some
creepy [ __ ] to his sister yes
um that's so creepy
it's I but my point being is that that's
when I thought okay now we're having
some real fun here is is during that
Vision sequence like this dark shit's
really working and then like the super
in your face shots when the camera just
the characters are perfectly centered
and they're just right there expressing
their emotions I think like they'll
really really worked a lot and I think
they I think they did a really good job
I think the at first I was like what
this guy's really strong with a stranger
who's really gandals at the beginning
and then right when the credit started
it was like that's just like it's got to
be a mislead yeah it's
too easy and they're doing a front
and while I thought this was really it
was like a fun episode it was a really
fun episode
um I do feel weirdly this is a very
disjointed Series in terms of its pacing
sometimes it's like it nailed it other
times you're like too boring
then this was the first one I went
rushed this is the first time I felt
that out of all the episodes where I'm
like somehow this feels rushed because
you've had such like deliberate pacing
and it's like
[Music]
yeah
and we're making the Rings and yeah the
freaking guys who I like the I thought
what was cool was the three um people
you know the one that people call um
what's the joke feminine feminine uh
yeah Believers or the faithful or
whatever they're called yeah yeah real
clever titles uh so them believing that
that was Sauron and that's because
before it was like the bathroom trying
to kill him like oh no they were like I
thought that was a cool reveal and that
helped kind of make me question of isn't
it right
then that kind of just got like they
would just pop in every episode to go
where on the hunt
and then they're just like you're so
wrong you've never gone out
and we're gonna lift the veil from your
mind and nope now we're done and they're
like you know he's not sorry he's the
other one oh [ __ ] it's going come on
guys
even the audience knew so it was uh it
was a felt a little fast and then like I
didn't even think they needed to
introduce the Rings and and it's like we
need to get there we need to get this
going I'm surprised I mean we have you
know 17 more to go but I would prefer I
but here's the honest God shirt I prefer
all those boring episodes
because I liked
I'd say I'm like 70 on this show uh
because there's some there's one episode
one or two that I there's one episode I
quite loved there's a couple that I
liked a hell of a lot
and this was like I would have preferred
this type of episode over any of the
episodes I thought were boring sure you
know sure yeah I'm just like yeah it's
like fun it's cheesy a little soap opera
I mean they've all been soap operate but
this this one was uh yeah it just kind
of just moved at a
it seemed to capture the the one episode
seemed to kind of go for the fantasy
sweeping Vibe like truly at times I
guess nah I don't even know more about
that
it's just kind of rushed it's just kind
of it was rushed I think overall this
season's a little bit of a mess but this
is uh this is in terms of a finale it
was fun I thought I had a fun time so
yeah the worst thing that could have
happened I was bored out of my mind but
there were things I really liked and um
the
yeah I don't know I just got weird
watches I feel like why does this one
feel rushed yeah and I mean I agree the
the G it's part partly yeah that is the
geography of events has been so spread
out and the common complaint has been
like you know we spent an hour in change
and not that much developed and then
here it's like man there's a lot of
developments coming out this is the big
reveals episode we're gonna build the
rings are on how she's gonna find her
new songs
there's like no he's gonna leave home
and that one guy died and yeah yeah this
is a lot there's a lot and it's funny
too because this is one of those
episodes where it doesn't feature the
whole cast you don't get Aaron deer at
all or any of the the other people there
you don't see a sildor again uh you know
we don't see Duran again or any of the
dwarves so like it's it is I'm
fascinated to I would love to see what
their cork board looked like of like the
displacement of events because it does
it oddly does feel
like weirdly structured overall and I'll
take a faster paced finale episode than
a draggy one but yeah it is a little bit
like this doesn't quite feel like it
matches the sensibility of the pacing
that came before it but you know
I don't know yeah I mean they're doing
some very obvious in the Gandalf phone
was so easy if he's gonna be gone I'm
curious if is is if if I'm curious as to
if they're going to go that far because
istar from my mild understanding is just
you know the estari are just the various
Wizards so it's not necessarily that
that's a name for him but you know I
absolutely can see them going hey it's
scanned out because I think Gandalf was
sent in the third age per the actual
lore again just vague you can correct me
but you know we're we're in the waist
deep in the second age so
John
I think what happened is they didn't
name him Gandalf so they can do it later
in case they want to change it
sure like that's conscientious okay
we're gonna call this guy Sauron
what
this skull's got a wizard in case we
changed our mind even though everything
about it is clearly referencing how
Gandalf became friends with Hobbit yes
yes and why he believed so much in them
whenever there's a big Stakes Mission
it's like I'm going to the hobbits and I
mean when he really starts speaking and
and yeah the veil also Reveals His
hidden vocabulary there are certain ways
he delivers lines that felt Ian McKellen
to me so when bad feminine person did
that that's what made him speak proper
yeah they lifted the veil on his mind or
whatever and and you know
uh well because these the the Wizards
are created and sent by uh I forget what
they're the my uh it's got to do with
the Valar and the various other like
governing uh
I must not remember that from when they
explained that yeah of course yes those
no those you would claim none of that
from any of what has been presented only
by this show itself I think uh yeah yeah
I forgot that not only should I sit
through eight hours of Television I
should read a book you should read all
the appendices you should read every
novel of surrounding context so that you
understand every bit
yeah it's not as it's you know that's
how every show ought to work every show
ought to have required background
material like that's a big question why
don't they ask it it just kept pulling
me out that they couldn't save sardock
yeah I was I think that was the
stupidest part of this whole episode and
someone's gonna come in this comments
and freaking me yeah read a book I'm
telling you everything this show has
shown me of what homeboy Gandalf maybe
not Gandalf can do I'm pretty sure a
stab wound is something
something especially when he's like you
know I'm going to sit here and uh admire
the Sun for a while I'm like looks like
he's in a pretty decent enough shape to
maybe perhaps and then we could have
done like a yeah that could have been a
light from low in frame and then we we
pull out to reveal oh there he is he's
TR he's trying to heal him up he was
just like can't do it can't do it I mean
I'm not even gonna try you see me do a
lot of other amazing incredible things
of foot
that little that's that boom not gonna
happen nope oh but someone's gonna be
like but there's a but the blade that
they stabbed him with has a type of sure
dark evil blade evil power where the
wound can't heal then I'm gonna be like
I missed the part where the show
explained that yeah
it seemed like all those other Boomerang
knives were fine hitting trees and
whatnot didn't seem like they were
particularly rotten for it the stuff I
turned in such a cheese I I hate when
because when when she's like throwing
the blades and then [ __ ] catches on
the on the sleeves and then they're like
all right
I can't mess this next one up yeah I
don't even know why I've got an amazing
shot and apparently how amazing I am at
Landing these
[Music]
statement oh no my foot
that's right I was like two I mean in
the editing it's fine enough but also I
was like I mean you know of all the
places to get stabbed that would throw
you off but I'm sure you could do
something in that situation to at least
recapitalize your power in that moment
it was it was funny entertaining I gotta
keep reassuring that and I will just
keep interjecting that as I continue to
make fun of the show so when it like
when you build up these three dudes who
um the Hocus Pocus gang and then
and then this whole time and then all
that is is
the only dialogue is you're sorrow we
want you that's all they say and then
reach your phone no he's not star on
fighting oh my God you guys amounted to
to nothing you awaken the veil within
him you you served as a good plot moment
and you killed off stardock which was
awesome
um
and uh Harford said a good goodbye uh I
I did like contextually reframing that
because it is usually like Frodo didn't
seem to give two shits about the hobbits
and uh
Samwise really did I just want to go
home from a Rosy Rosie and uh elbows
like I'm sick of these people yeah he
doesn't suck and and then uh her she had
a an already had a really
sad emotional good departure from them
and she was like well we'll find you
again we'll see you again you'll come
back and I'm like you guys travel yeah
how is he ever she's gonna find you you
guys give me that's a lot to ask the
last scene in season five will be Nori
on Eagle back just like are they over
here no it was
cruising the land until we find him it's
definitely again the fight that they had
at the end was definitely it was very
reminiscent yes sorry Mom Saruman
Gandalf yeah yeah no for sure
it's probably him
but they've just been so precious about
the lore up until this point the ball
Rock didn't come back no we didn't check
in with Duran no
um that's how they get us the king of
the elves is the worst yeah man that was
every episode was just like I'm a stoic
[ __ ] Gil Gala does not seem that
great and uh I don't really have much
hope and I'm going to beans I'm going to
be very condescending yeah always aren't
we an inspirational race I deserves to
live on more
I'm like I I like elrond and Keller
brimbor but yeah I feel like they could
have
made a different Choice with Gil galad
it should have been two episodes this
final episode yeah they could have
really sold on the reveal and created a
wonder and a sense of hope of creating
the me thrill instead right when they
start getting to work glad you're always
like an evil bad bad bad news
[Laughter]
oh wait who's this guy what did he say
he's bad he's bad suspect them now I
suspect him the guy I brought here I
suspected just like what the what's
going on this is so fast well and the
way she bursts in again fun and
entertaining must reassure I prefer over
barring any day of the week anything
amazing didn't work was still amusing
and fun yes but it was I was sort of
element
glorious I was surprised that she she
bursts in and I I get that it's the awe
of like oh the Rings are being completed
and and these such powerful devices but
at the same time I I figured it would be
like let them know yeah what the [ __ ]
you know like tell them what you just
discovered
beholding it sauron's on to us yeah and
he just like if he helped us do this it
must not be good yeah it's stupid it's
really stupid
funny ass Choice that's stupid because
it is like
it it is it is a dumb choice to me it's
really dumb she should tell them because
of everything just said that you're like
yo he's on to you you should let them
know or is she like
pretty embarrassed because I mean when
he was in my mind he was like I wasn't
gonna feel when you find out there's
Sovereign [ __ ] you're right dude well
helped him out but but maybe we'll tell
them when we were in war with him maybe
I'll tell them at a point where it makes
me look the most suspicious instead of
right when I found out so that I can try
and stamp this fire around as he spreads
I'm like I feel like in her position and
then you know I've never been
responsible for something so so horrific
but
I don't know why I emphasize that uh in
her position as a [ __ ] she was banging
it that's right that's right I feel like
in that position [ __ ] if you found out
that that was the case you would want to
immediately inform people just because
that's the less suspicious thing to do
you know
yeah guys I kept explaining for the show
I was like okay soon maybe uh sauron's
taking over uh Galadriel was that what's
going on because uh why would you be so
[ __ ] dumb in this moment
I did yeah it's odd because yeah she's
so committed to like no sauron's out
there he's he's coming back and I gotta
stop it me and so like with all that
determination I am surprised and I too I
mean I did like I did appreciate like
one thing that got better about previous
episodes looking back in this episode
was the way he's like no I told you all
this and you just didn't believe it and
for me that was a neat moment to be like
okay we see so many like headstrong
assured characters like this whose
judgment is like otherworldly and so
this was a moment of like we see that
and that lends a lot of credence to Hall
Brand's character sympathetically but
then we find out oh damn that assurance
and that you know a fixation of belief
doesn't always pan out well you know and
sometimes you do walk right into a trap
and I feel like like that was nice but
then yeah to come right out of it and to
have her rush back and not say anything
I mean he's it's sure if you put it in
the script the way he said it but
there's a lot of other things he said
too that were playing off of the things
he's had yeah true like okay okay King
of the Southlands and my people and the
choices I've made him you know the South
he will be king of the Southlands
it's just it's just code
it's just double speak
he really like got it a character here
yeah no he agreed on recovery cop I'm
like what was the point of all the
it makes me wonder why play the
reluctant hero so that that's the part
I'm talking about why commit so much to
the reluctant hero role like I just
don't understand having the episodes
were like it's your cunning how brand
you should rise up again and then that
episode is the blacksmith and he's like
I shouldn't go
why have any of of that these private
moments whatever no one's around a
witness is it you just don't understand
the choice of that yeah and I I I it
puts me on a seesaw because I think to
my it's all in the head Cannon like you
said it's like you're filling in the
gaps yourself and so for me I'm I'm
sitting here wondering like okay so is
this the kind of thing where he doesn't
cool like you know the Sauron we all
know as as you know fully formed uh you
know at the end of the second age and
all that stuff you know maybe he's not
that guy yet sure but also it certainly
seems critique and Powerful right yeah
once they reveal and he does the Mind
thing it's like oh okay you you seem
very much like you know who you are what
you're trying to do
Etc but I know that there are supposed
to be many faces of Sauron and this is
after all this stuff with morgoth so
part of me was like okay so is it maybe
the kind of thing where he too is sort
of having an Awakening or pulling back
of some kind of existential Veil but
then you know that's answered here or it
feels like it's answered here with yeah
the the turn that he goes through this
whole episode and so yeah I feel like
that
it's it's a fun twist or reveal if you
want to call it that but I do yeah they
could have made
I don't know without I don't know how
they would have done it without giving
it away necessarily but I feel like they
could have made something more
convincing out of yeah him
playing these parts or walking among
humans and elves this way you know
rather than yeah feeling like some kind
of crazy you know Joker plan
[Music]
it's like I had to get myself lost at
sea and hope I got discovered by the
right Elf or whatever or you know then I
would get taken to prison because if
you've got the mental ability unless he
needed to be by the me throw or
something I don't know because he was
like I want to stay with the queen
region and stay in this people and just
be a blacksmith and I don't want to go
to war and I don't want to do any of
these things are doing all these things
that I don't want to do I don't want to
be helpful Warrior guy ah fine I'll do
it because I feel bad
because it's like this this the the way
the scripting worked was like okay Adar
definitely has enemy yeah
and that's what he manipulated his way
there but I'm like but what if with all
the [ __ ]
by all the Bulls when like in the
moments when golaterals not even in the
room with him oh why all the [ __ ]
it's just like what it wouldn't have
hurt him to just be like
you're right it's time for me I should I
should go on yeah I should go fight with
you because then then there you go
what's what's suspicious about that I'm
the king of the Southlands and I'm here
to find what's suspicious about it yeah
like you can go and and you'll just be
there yeah yeah with all the [ __ ]
and it's even less suspicious I guess
yeah
it's yeah it's an odd set of motivations
that they play out in the course of this
he didn't say he was King of the
Southlands she said it yeah she's the
dumb one who said who said I know what
the [ __ ] you're residual yeah no your
sigil is oh you're the heir I took it
off we need to convince the audience
you're the new Aragorn
he took it off but she didn't know a
thousands she knew all that but she knew
all that
but she didn't know like wait a minute
no one should be king
that's a thousand years ago that King
died yeah it doesn't happen nobody is
taking up the mantle since I wonder why
not
I just poke so bunch of holes in this
you don't have an air I guess you didn't
it's not that it doesn't it just doesn't
feel as clever to me it doesn't but
executed in a thrilling well-shot one
yeah I hope that season two they tighten
some of these things up but yes they're
they're clearly have a knack for some
some rollicking visual Flair
yeah it was funny a lot funnier
that's yeah
why would she surprised to see Oprah
no no why was she like what are you
doing
like why why did she surprised to see
all right I don't even remember what I
thought it was like a kind of relief
thing of like oh oh a friend was that
the emotion she was playing I don't know
your guess is as good as mine honestly
it's the emotion I saw yeah what are you
doing yeah did you even say that to him
at one point I think she said
yeah I mean because I get why he was
like he's like you're supposed to be
like not on Earth what are you doing
here yeah
yeah you you've uh not perished since I
yeah
like this is where elrond would be
yeah yeah
true
no I can't I can't argue that
but it's good it made for a unique and
memorable moment
yeah yeah
Magnum
my last thing I want to make fun of
the Rings
the wedding rings they have here the
brightly colored stones in them yeah now
I know it's not the one ring to rule
them all all right because they got way
more to produce as the hit original song
says at the end I got like 17 more to
figures right uh
the thing about that one ring was it
felt like especially with Peter Jackson
filmed it was I felt like it was this
like 100 pound ring you know like that
Rings
like two hands pick that thing over here
you know what I mean it's gonna change
size on you
and these the Rings here just look like
they just kept doing like this very
orchestral like sweeping Michael Bay
shots around the rings that oh my drone
I just look like regular rings and I'm
not really quite getting the emotion
that you're telling me to feel right now
you're filming around rings that don't
even look real they I can't I couldn't
tell if they were digital or practical
Rings my guess is that was a CGI just
like a complete CGI why if it is then
I'm even more likely to make fun of the
CGI rings I can't wait to edit the
reaction for a few hours just for people
to be mad at me for how I'm talking
about this I I hope that they did it
practically but you never know
I feel I don't know I just get the sense
that for how expensive this was or just
like make it CG make them otherworldly
or something but it could be wrong I
would be happy to do it they look like
just they look like Rings
yes I hope they're practical if you know
comment below I was uh funny
anyway guys uh the rings of power we'll
see what the trailer for season two
looks like
in production now before it's coming we
make a commitment because
I think overall
what we got was a fine series sure uh
not a great one because the reason why
this is George RR Martin writes better
than J.R.R Tolkien that's what the war
is about right that's wowie that's what
it is that's the comment that launched a
thousand angry responses when I see
people say all the time I'm like oh I
need you guys to realize
neither one of them wrote any of the
students
I'd be well to be fair George RR Martin
at least has some sign some type of say
or influence or can at least be like hey
I got an opinion very true you know very
true he came out and was like Patty
Constantine your viseris is better than
mine so the people who come out and say
you know like
about jrl tokens riding with this this
the people defend this like
yeah he didn't write this
factors usually like four to eight
screenwriters every episode Oh weird see
I feel like most of the discords I've
heard about Tolkien is like he's rolling
in his grave I'm saying the ones who
defend the show sure I just haven't seen
those Defenders I wanna I wanna talk to
those Defenders specifically who are
like I love tolkien's writing and this
is that if you lead with crapping on
this show sure right at the top you will
get those look at Paul happy spoilers
yeah that's fair
you'll find a lot at that yeah
especially because he shells for House
of the dragon that fraud of course he
does
um so anyway he has to a patron of the
day shut up
you're the one man you live in what
could possibly be real life Middle Earth
you're the real Gandalf of this channel
you're wise you can [ __ ] [ __ ] well I
mean Scotland is is also you know pretty
Lush in ways and and you know it's got
some of that you know they got Scottish
accents half the people in the you know
hard foots and stuff or at least you
know various uk-esque not everyone and
Lord of the Rings is talking like this
you know
so uh Daniel
still works the shed the shadow still
works Daniel and uh hey you're wise you
are a a concoctor of potions and and
things like that you could be you know
one of the is tar for for us you know
guide us along the path of righteousness
and help us restore both fairness and
Power
and uh keep on pledging that's the best
that's the most important part love you
buddy and we'll talk soon
that was the reveal yeah yeah good for
him
it's good for you now a Harry Potter
series I'd watch that sure I mean yeah I
think Fantastic Beasts would have been a
good series also that and then they
could
build up their new Voldemort instead of
doing it in the jump between one movie
and the next
like I feel like the Fantastic Beasts
movie went okay we're starting in Harry
Potter one and then we're skipping a
Harry Potter six in terms of the Threat
Level here I still don't feel like this
show has well Justified its existence
uh
[Music]
uh your main character
where you're like you know she's gonna
be fine sure you know they're going to
win because of the opening of the fight
and then you know even by the end of
that when the major Journey happens with
the ring to destroy the Mordor she's
going to be fine
uh it's about the drama that we share
along the way you know who's gonna lose
eventually yeah you're building up your
big Baddie who you know damn well not
only that he's going to lose but how
he's going to lose you that's fair yes
and
that like it's not doing enough to make
me like care about the new characters
like
oh no is Nori gonna be all right that
should be fine I hope so because but as
long as as maybe Gandalf survives it'll
be fine
he's radagaston brown yes he's sarmon
it'll be all that would be good yeah
that would be that would be interesting
like oh my God that's why they sense
darkness in him yeah and Saruman wasn't
always you know the the you know he was
a good wizard at first yeah absolutely
so that actually [ __ ] it might be right
it might be Saruman all right I'm gonna
claim that right now is my prediction
and Gandalf like definitely kind of
looked up to him sure yeah and maybe I'd
have to check the history but maybe
Saruman was uh on uh in Middle Earth
before Gandalf who knows
one Google search away let's do it this
is the best shout out oh Saruman and
Middle Earth before Gandalf
Saruman
wow I have one simple question
are we in the thousands of the third age
now we're in the second age right now so
this doesn't really jive with any of the
Gandalf or Saruman lore apparently
unless I'm misreading the timeline but
you know it's downloading yeah so I want
to [ __ ] know
the characters were about the same age
as Gandalf or Sauron oh my God and okay
it's definitely
filled within time itself
damn then it must be Gandalf but it
would be cool if it was Saruman
be interesting yeah it would be all
right we're done
[Music]